MICHEL DEGRAFF: You know, so
why this hashtag for the course?
The hashtags, Stay Woke?
Well I love it,
because in a way,
it's one of these phrases that
take a very complex concept,
and that makes that accessible
to the larger public.
Because Stay Woke
is a way to talk
about critical consciousness.
And what we've seen
in the past elections
is this increase of
quote-unquote "fake news."
And one thing which
I've been trying
to share with the students is
that this concept of fake news
isn't at all a new phenomenon.
So in fact, if you
look at the way
history is taught in the US--
if you look at, say, Howard
Zinn's book about history--
it tells us how
our history books
are filled with fake news.
So the point is that, it's not
just fake news that's fake.
And what the students get
to see through, for example,
the Haitian revolution is
that, in the textbooks,
most of them-- actually,
almost all of them, maybe,
except for one or two--
they got to learn
lots of details
about the French Revolution.
And then the
American Revolution.
So they know all the
things about that.
But almost none of
them knew about Haiti.
But if you think of
what revolution means,
this revolution has
had much more impact
when it comes to human
rights, civil liberties,
than both the US revolution
and the French one.
And the question that I
ask them is, why is it
that they went through
the elementary school,
the high school, some of them
most of the college years,
without ever hearing about
the Haitian revolution?
Right?
Which, in fact, it has
been much more potent
than both the French
one and the US one.
And to me, that was a great way
to introduce to them the idea
that, you have to stay woke.
You have to
understand why history
is being taught in such a biased
way, that excludes the one
revolution that actually
allowed this concept of equality
among all human
beings to become true.
Because both in
France, and in the US,
when they were claiming liberty,
equality, fraternity, there
were still people
who were in chains.
You know, in fact, blacks
were still in slavery.
Women couldn't vote.
It's only in Haiti that
revolution took its
really meaning in really
changing the world order.
And in creating this
possibility for all human beings
to be equal.
But yet, it's not taught
in the classroom in the US.
And to me, that's one of the
most blatant cases of fake news
that's become so much a
part of the way children
are educated in the US.
So Stay Woke means to be alert
to this kind of propaganda that
passes for history.
That's Stay Woke.
And of course, we
look at other examples
where they,
themselves, participate
in these hierarchies of
knowledge that actually
subserve hierarchies of power.
That's Stay Woke.